well meanwhile the White House says that
President Joe Biden has spoken to the
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu on the phone on this call
Netanyahu again reiterated that Israel
will not initiate a ceasefire and then
in an interview with American Media he
also said that Israel will maintain a
security presence in Gaza after the war
I think Israel will
for an indefinite period will have the
overall uh security responsibility
because we've seen what happens when we
don't have have it when we don't have
that security responsibility what we
have is the eruption of Hamas Terror on
a scale that we couldn't imagine Mr
Balin thank you for your time today let
me start by asking you what you made of
netanyahu's comments about continuing a
security responsibility quote
indefinitely in Gaza was this a not so
veiled reference to reoccupying the
strp well I'm not sure that this is
going to be the case I My Hope Is that
Hamas will no more rule the the Gaza
stream Hamas was the
main factor on the on the Palestinian
side which was against a two-state
solution and what happened a month ago
was crazy totally crazy this massacre we
cannot allow it neither the the right
nor the left to allow Hamas to remain
there in power and once Hamas is not in
power I think that many things will
happen and to speak now about the
Israeli present military presence in in
Gaza once Hamas is not there is I
believe much premature I hope that
eventually we will have a solution with
the PLO which is the legitimate
representative of the Palestinian people
on the issue of the two-state solution
based on the 67 borders with land swaps
and that Gaza will will be a part of
course of this state now if the parties
will argue and and debate about security
measure this is something else but it is
impossible to to say now that whatever
happens Israel will remain the security
wise and be able to do whatever it wants
we still don't know what exactly will be
the kind of regime in Gaza once Hamas
hopefully is not leading this area so
you say these comments and speculation
are premature I know the National
Security Council in Israel had said that
it didn't actually have plans for the
future before it engaged in the Gaza
Strip so let me ask you what is the end
game now is there a plan or are we
actually hearing these sorts of comments
from Netanyahu because there isn't a
plan well you know I I'm not sure
I actually hope that this government of
Netanyahu will not Prevail politically
after the war so it will not be the one
to to call the shots hopefully it will
be another government ER which will do
its best to promote H peace between
Israelis and Palestinians it and it will
be as I said much easier if Hamas is not
leading Gaza so you suggested that
there's division between the right and
left on this issue on what happens next
although there is Unity on getting rid
of mass it is always I mean we are a
democracy it is always there of course
and of course and of course there are
many
differences but about the the campaign
now in Gaza in order to prevent Hamas to
continue and Rule Gaza here I believe
that there is a very large consensus in
the Israeli society and in Israeli
politic well let me ask you then about
about the The Next Step because we're
talking a little bit about what might
possibly come after if you say that
everyone is is Unified on getting rid of
Hamas I'm curious about where public
opinion is on this outside of politics
do popular forces do people in the
streets do they want Israeli forces in
the Gaza Strip after this is over or or
some kind of arrangement like in the
occupied West
Bank I think that the Israelis like the
Palestinians
will at the end of the day support any
signed agreement between the two parties
so the the question of whether Israeli
Security Forces will remain there or be
there in the in the coming in in the
near future is in my view too difficult
for a a public opinion po or or
something like this and the main issue
is whether they want peace with the
other side right now on both sides you
see the hatred and feels of Revenge and
all these things which are more than
natural but once we see together it will
be different hopefully and people will
understand that peace is the only
solution for both of us Israelis and
Palestinians well speaking of of peace
and a solution Mr Bal and you yourself
were instrumental in getting the Oslo
process going from what you're hearing
now in Israel particularly in political
circles can I ask you where the
conversation is in terms of any kind of
a long-term political settlement there's
obviously been plenty of talk outside of
Israel about a two-state solution is
there a framework right now being
discussed in in various political
factions
there it's back on the agenda no doubt
for years for
years the issue was not on the agenda
and when people like myself talk to to
to world leaders about the peace in the
Middle East peace between us and the
Palestinians people I mean they they
would say to meos it is a very good idea
this is the aim we hope that it will
happen but it cannot happen neither
because of your government which is
right is no because of the Palestinian
situation which is split between between
fat and Kamas now the issue of the
two-state solution is back on the agenda
you hear President Biden speaking about
it in every speech that he delivers and
so I hope that out of this dark moment
of of the the
a conflict the the lethal conflict the
violent conflict between the
Palestinians in Gaza and and Israel
there might grow something very
different and this is the need or the
understanding on both sides that they
don't have a better solution rather than
peace well we all certainly hope that
something more constructive will come
out of this Yosi B and there a former
Israeli Minister of Justice and also a
former negotiated during the Oslo Peace
Accords thank you so much for joining us
again on aler sir thank you for your
time